الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
يحتفل اليوم بعيد ميلاده ال 77 لكن عيد
ميلاده جاي متزامن مع حدث ما احد بيتمناه
فكما دقائق سيمثل ترامب امام المحكمه
الاتحاديه في ميامي بخصوص 37 تهمه جنائيه
موجهه له بتتعلق باساءه التعامل مع اسرار
حكوميه واحتفاضه بشكل غير قانوني بوسائق
كان نقلها من البيت الابيض من بعد ما
انتهت ولايته في 2021 وبترتبط بشكل اساسي
بالامن القومي وكان ترامب قال قبلها انه
ما عنده اي وثائق قبل ما يداهموا الامن
الفيدرالي العام الماضي منزله
فيصادر صناديق من الوثائق قالوا انه من
المفترض تكون في الارشيف الوطني وبيعتبر
ترامب اول رئيس امريكي بتوجه له اتهامات
جنائيه المحاكمه ممنوع نقلها وتصويرها لكن
اللي المفروض انه يصير بمجرد وصول ترامب
للمحكمه انه سيوضع رسميا
رهن الاعتقال وبعدين راح اخذ بصماته
الكترونيا اما بالنسبه للصوره الشهيره
اللي خاصه بالمتهمين هو اسمها المعروفه
انه بالمقشط فمو معروف اذا راح ياخذها او
لا او بعدين مرجح انه يتنازل محاموت عن
القراءه الرسميه للائحه الاتهامات 37
واللي متوقع انه قدام القاضي يقول انه
بريء منها وقيل انه متوقع الطلب من القاضي
كمان تقييد اتصالات باي من الشهود لمنع اي
عبث محتمل وبعدها يتوقع الافراج عنه بتعهد
شخصي يعني افراج من دون كفاله ومتوقع
بعدها انه يلقي ترامب خطاب علني امام
انصاره في ميامي من نادي الجولف كل هذه
الاتهامات مشاهدينا بتتزامن مع ترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه واللي كثير
من الناس قالوا انه ممكن تؤثر على فرصه في
العوده الى البيت الابيض بيتهم بايدن
والديمقراطيين بانهم هم اللي وردتها وظلما
بكل هذه القصص لمنع تر مره ثانيه ولكن
ترمت ماشي بمبدا يا جبل ما يهزك ريح واعلن
انه ما راح يتنازل عن الترشح بغض النظر عن
نتيجه معركه القانونيه من المحاكمه مثل ما
قلت لكم مشاهدينا مو مصوره وممكن حتى دخول
ترامب للمحكمه يكون من كراج تحت الارض
يعني ما راح يتمكن انصاره من انهم يشوفوه
مع انهم بداوا فعليا في التجمع امام
المحكمه اللي شاهد محيطها استنفار امني
مكثف واستعدادات امنيه لتجمع خمسين الف
متظاهر وحقيقه كثير من الناس خايفه من انه
ينعاد سيناريو احداث الكابتل او انه تصير
اعمال شغب وفوضى
حتى الان في تجمعات لانصار ترامب امام
المحكمه مثل ما قلنا لكن اجدد الصور بتظهر
انه الاعلام والصحفيين امام المحكمه اكثر
بكثير من الانصار حتى الان
[موسيقى]